Claudine gay is gone but the media and
race hustl and Liberals are doubling
down to defend the poster child of
Dei gay stepping down as president of
Harvard after 50 examples of plagiarism
emerged and her embarrassing
Congressional testimony on
antisemitism Hart has expelled loads of
students for the academic crime of
plagiarism but not if you're copycat
Claudine she is set to keep her nearly
$1 million annual salary she also has an
Army of sympathetic liberal journalists
crying racism and blaming conservatives
for her resignation check out these
headlines how the right toppled
Harvard's president Harvard president's
resignation highlights new conservative
weapon against College's
plagiarism and conservatives see Claud
Dean Gay's resignation as a
victory and of course liberal pundits
are going to bat for gay
listen what happened to Claud and gay
was mob pressure there is this sort of
open War war on black progress black
history um claudian gay the president uh
of Harvard University at least up until
she resigned um is now the latest
casualty of that there very much is a
racial component I don't think it's fair
to say all of her critics were racist
but certainly a few of them were it
looks as though she was targeted the
fact that she's a black woman and the
first person uh who is a a black
American to lead Harvard uh only
added to their thirst to Dethrone her
that 300 million but what all these race
Hustlers fail to mention is that the
white upen president was the first ivy
league head to roll and the other white
lady MIT president Sally corn Bluff is
fearing for her job she just sent an
email to students outlining steps the
school's taking to understand the nature
and extent of anti-Semitism on campus uh
okay Greg Gutfeld um did you expect this
reaction they are now defending
plagiarism of course I mean gay LED this
I mean I love how she refused to defend
Jews and then she cries racism that's
identity jiujitsu emphasis on Jew but
it's great to see like if you saw AP AP
is getting barbecued for framing this as
you know conservatives pouncing or it's
like they've weaponized plagiarism which
is actually what does that mean
weaponizing something bad does that mean
getting rid of it I don't really know I
I'm all for weaponizing crime and
Corruption too if that's what it is but
the great thing about AP is they got
totally eviscerated because of community
notes on X which then just printed the
Litany of her infractions but you know
who's a threat to to diversity people
claiming that this firing is a threat to
diversity because no one in their right
Minds who runs a business will hire a
person under the assumption that they
can never fire them and this is the
message no one's going to hire you no
one's going to hire you a minority if
they think they can't fire you if you
suck so there's this unconscious
reluctance to hire a person of color
because the back in your head and it
could be the boss is a person of color
are thinking well will this be trouble
down the line like what if this person
doesn't work out discrimination
obviously illegal but you would be a
fool not to think in this climate where
lawsuits discrimination lawsuits are
incentivized and met with large
settlements that an angry fired employee
AKA G who actually resigned will accuse
you of racism once you decide to pull
the trigger so that's some you see this
now you even see this in like small
businesses that are run by whites blacks
Asians Hispanics you know that that like
when they hear these stories they go you
know what we're going to stick to our
group because we because you know what
we don't want to put our we as a
precaution you know we're observing
reality you know victimhood is
profitable so we don't want to step out
and hire somebody else because that
could come back and blow up in our face
did you hear any evidence that the
people that were asking for Gay's
resignation were racially motivated no
and and but it's interesting I love the
point about she was saying like how hard
it was to be targeted yeah with racial
animist was like well but that was the
question that Alise stonic asked at the
hearing which was is calling for the
elimination of the Jews something that's
against the code of contact conduct and
she couldn't say yes so then you have
the on plagiarism what's interesting is
that the New York Times is the one who
then started asking Harvard why aren't
you responding to the Washington Free
Beacon inquiries It's Curious that the
AP journalism journalists would not be
worried about plagiarism they write for
a living and soon the robots are going
to write for the living for a living and
no one's going to be able to do anything
about the plagiarism from the robots
when that happens are they allowed to
plagiarize the robots um well the robots
are going to plagiarize everybody else
who's going to police that yeah well the
Free Beacon and thankfully so one of my
favorite reactions was from a liberal on
Twitter who said well let's just start
digging into the scholarly records and
academic writings of conservatives and
it's like okay yeah let's do that let's
go for it who hasn't done that already
they've done that already you might
learn something while reading the one
thing is also the question is then how
was I think the bigger question how was
gay chosen in the first place how will
they undertake the next search what are
they looking for what does Harvard want
and the pain for Harvard is not going to
stop until they're honest about their
situation and very clear about what sort
of rigorous scholarly standards they
want to uphold and if they don't do that
then it can just become like any other
state
school does Harvard now have to hire an
African-American woman no as a
replacement because a lot of people are
calling on Harvard to do that I don't
think so I think that they should hire
whoever makes the most sense for the
school and certainly take into account
what has happened over the course of the
last month and where they want to go in
the future and I think that's what they
will do and it doesn't mean if they do
hire a black woman or another person of
a diverse background that it's a Pity
hire of some kind or a Dei hire there
are plenty of very well-qualified people
to do this job and you are right they
have in the past dug into the background
of conservative Scholars we know for
instance Neil Gorsuch plagiarized
portions of his 2006 book he took from a
1984 Indiana Law Journal article and he
said it wasn't malicious he said this
was a citation mistake and I saw people
were exploding about this online you
know shouldn't this be what we're
focusing on and there is a key
difference if you are leading the top or
one certainly one of the top but the top
academic institution in the world and
your back ground is in that versus
having done what Justice gorsage did and
I wish that he hadn't but it's the
reality of the situation um plagiarism
as a weapon which was the terminology
that the AP had used um plagiarism or do
incredible work is the Holy Grail of
Academia it is the thing that you pride
yourself on it is the thing that gets
you remembered the thing that your
students love about you um I I think
that kind of terminology is so strange
and off based and I bill Amman who was
obviously seminal in this happening
published I think it was like 4,000
words this screen about how he ended up
becoming part of this and Trace retraced
his steps saying you know I showed up on
October 8th right the day after this
before there was any organization on any
level and what was particularly
disturbing to him was that he was
confronted with this Paradigm which Greg
talks about a lot between the oppressor
and the oppressed and that people can
only think in the what what do you call
the prison of two prison of two ideas
Jessica right read my last book I
actually did oh okay never mind um no it
was great
um the part that I found most
interesting about amman's letter was
when he talks about Dei and I think that
we need to be
careful in bucketing it as just one
thing and saying like this is about
hiring unqualified black women that's
not what Dei is about there's the side
of Dei which is about focusing on on
ensuring that people get a chance to
rise up and get roles that they have
been systemically uh discriminated
against in the past and
then the people who actually get those
roles who are people of color and the
truth is is most Dei officers like 76%
of Dei Chief diversity offic officers
are white yeah with green ha not with
green with green hair that was
statistically accurate you can go check
it was definitely not judge okay first
of all you know one citation or mis
citation by uh justice Gorsuch doesn't
compare to 50 credible claims of
plagiarism by a woman who did not have
the background the intelligence or the
academic uh support to be the president
of the the the most sophisticated and
the most sought-after University in the
country there's no comparison between
the two number two is the fact that Dei
is about equality of outcome not
opportunity I think that equality of
outcome is great but when you're talking
about someone who going to lead the
university it doesn't work and the fact
is that this Sally cornbluth from MIT
today she wrote a memo to her students
and this woman gets it she said you know
what I must not have been uh I must not
have understood how serious this was or
how bad it was for Jewish students on
campus she shows how easy it is to keep
your job all she had to do was recognize
that Jewish students are being
intimidated on campus and you can't
allow it Claudine gay in her letter
where she resigned doesn't apologize for
anything only talks about herself it's
me me me now Claud and gay only has
herself to blame she didn't have the
academic Excellence she didn't have the
Integrity or the moral core to say the
calling for the destruction of any group
is against the code of conduct of
Harvard she didn't have that Minal
intelligence that she needed and what
the leftist saying by saying this is all
about racism they can't figure out who
the victims are in the criminal justice
system the victims are not the people
who've been victimized it's the criminal
with Hamas the people who've been
victimized are Hamas the terror
organization not the other people and
the same with Claudine gay she's a
victim because she's black not the
Jewish students who were invisible to
these people so in the end she could
very easily have resolved this and Bill
Amman is right he's right that board has
to go they threatened a defamation
lawsuit to a New York newspaper I think
it was the post because they wanted to
write about the defamation of Claudine
gay and they didn't want it to come out
and they said that 50 instances of
plagiarism it was it was not intentional
it wasn't even Reckless it was not
misconduct well kids at Harvard and
they're having their worst day they're
getting thrown out of Harvard with a
permanent mark on their record if they
plagiarized so you know and also last
thing on the board they sought
retribution Against The Whistleblower
who told the Press about uh the
plagiarism so Atman is right this
Claudine gay she deserved to go and
that's the end of it had nothing to do
with race you can ask Liz Mill but he
does want uh the MIT woman to go well
she's not going you know why I don't
know he wrote that before she wrote this
so we'll see we'll see really good
contributions from all of you and I
really mean that except for you I know
yeah insane liberal policies forcing
Democrats to sound like Republicans hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else